[Music]
a couple days ago i was uh barbecuing i
was having a barbecue uh my girlfriend
was had some family over and we were
having a little uh a little party a
little daytime saturday party and i got
a call from a number that i thought was
um a telemarketer i was gonna pick it up
and then hang up and then block the
number that's that's what i do that's
how i do it and it was a number that i
didn't recognize from miami uh and they
said hi this is lil nazex's manager
and i said
okay and i could tell she was sincere
right away and she had gotten my numbers
somehow she explained and
apparently lil nas x is a huge alvin and
the chipmunks fan and he had tweeted out
earlier that day
something to this effect i'm i'm
paraphrasing lil
lil's tweet so if my reps don't get me
and alvin and the chipmunks theme party
for my birthday i'm gonna be really sad
something like that that doesn't sound
like a very little tweet that sounds
like like a regular length tweet
it was a yeah it was a normal tweet from
lille
so they didn't want to disappoint lil
they didn't want him they wanted he a
grown man yeah he's 23. okay so we did
the math and found that he was born in
he was eight when the movie came out
isn't that crazy eight when that first
movie came out so i um
i dutifully
uh responded i recorded myself but then
i thought because she she suggested
maybe i record birth like happy birthday
sing happy birthday but i said but i
don't have the equity you know the
computer to do it it's all digitized as
we've talked about probably too much on
the show and so i found an app like a
chipmunk app that you can do it yourself
so i sang them happy birthday happy
birthday to um
happy birthday dear lil nos ex wow well
you don't not fulfill lil nosex requests
that's what i thought yeah you did the
right thing i thought so and it was just
a little favor
um anyway here's our little show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i am
your medium-sized host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my um
you're less little than i am you're
taller than i am host i'm a little wider
than you two yeah but you've lost quite
a bit of weight and you're like a bit of
weight make it sound like i have quite a
bit to lose i lost maybe five pounds oh
really well it's there are pounds that
really showed a bit of weight well
that didn't mean quite a bit that
sounded right and it's okay if you're
overweight though i don't i don't mean
to
yeah why would you be offended by this
i'm not why are you suggesting you
seemed incredulous no no no i didn't
lose that much and you have a little
patch on your nose uh yeah i have a zit
uh next to my in my t-zone um anyway
little nausea why are we talking about
little pimples and little nauseas and
that's um
maybe he'll be a future uh little friend
of the show well of course i said to the
manager um yeah nothing's narrow no you
scratch my back i um if a little favor
for a little favor and um i so i said i
suggested that i send her i sent her a
video i probably looked like such a
boomer in this video i was like hey
little nauseas it's lil justin
long and um happy birthday can you
please change your
professional name to little justin long
that'd be so that would be really funny
it'd be funny it would make news would i
get in trouble for appropriating uh no i
think there are white lils
oh yeah there's little dickey little
dickie yeah
and we shouldn't be talking man
we can talk about why that's true oh no
very white that's true we can definitely
talk about that um but i i never heard
back from them really and when i said
when i was like well maybe you could be
a guest on the i'd love for him to be on
the podcast and she was like yeah
okay and she was i i could tell she just
wanted to get this thing done she was
like ah yeah i don't want to like deal
with anything other than satisfying
little nasdaq's is that's hard to say
lil nas x's request you your eyes
basically uh why are we talking about
lil nos x um well because x is the roman
numeral for ten okay and two two x's
would be if it's little nausea x x which
it's not but that would be twenty
and lil nas x xx would be well 30 and
also scandalous looking that that'd be a
good name for a
porn star little nas triple x
yeah that is funny yeah or or big nas x
but double x would be 20 yes in roman
numerals yes and um
one of the most famous bands of the last
30 years is a band called matchbox 20
and uh the lead singer of that band is
our esteemed guest today it's rob thomas
yeah that's it's quite a segue you just
made from the nasdaq
but you could have just said
also a record also a musician yeah also
a very successful musician yep yeah but
i like the roman numeral angle
it's clever it was yeah it was a
probably one of the most the biggest
stretches of an intro that's okay it's
worth it because the story was funny
yeah it's a funny story and uh and yet
to be um determined how it ends maybe
he'll be a guest on the show maybe
probably not so rob thomas yes our
current guest robin thomas
thomas rob thomas
um
is was part of the soundtrack to our
formative years
and uh matchbox 20 was a huge band um
late starting in the late 90s and as
forgettable they continue to be a very
popular band and they're still recording
together still playing shows together
those songs are on the radio all the
time all the time all the time and
there's so many hits that like you
forget that so many can be attributed i
feel that way about third eye blind a
little bit like they have so many so
many bunch of those and a classic
collaboration with santana smooth man
that was like everywhere i think it was
the number two biggest single of all
time it was that you told me that after
i did the interview
and um a monster hit it was it was so we
talk about that we talk about how the
band came to be how he went from this
just a small town florida boy to one of
the biggest bands in the world it's um
and you had never met him before never
met
um obviously been aware of him since i
was in high school and um
so here he is let's hear from him yes
the hit maker himself
uh
one of our the first member of matchbox
20 to be on the show
my new friend i think rob thomas
[Music]
hey rob hey justin hey thank you i'm
sorry about being um about the time push
uh it's been a lot of technical
difficulties here it's crazy i i
appreciate the fact that you think that
i have something else to do i really do
i that's a flattering thing to assume i
do assume that
it makes me feel very very good
that i have some sort of a life outside
of just waiting for someone to zoom me
that's true that's true i guess that
always does feel good to me too i i try
not to correct them i don't like to set
the record straight but i um
yeah i just think like if someone's seen
you before they they automatically
assume that you're very very busy all
the time
that's true that's true yeah well only
because especially somebody like you who
has done
so much and it seems to be like
ubiquitous it's there's the assumption
that yes you're always
doing something i would i would assume
that about you no i just try to try and
start little fires every now and then
that someone can catch that's just like
that's my that's my career plan so
here's what's happening rob my every
time i log on to my computer here i'm
i'm in massachusetts so sorry it's a
nice frozen lake oh okay you're over
here on my side of the world oh where
are you i'm in new york oh great yes
okay so um
uh yeah all right well we should have
just done this in person um
my son uh is grew up in newton
oh no kidding it's like pleasantville
right like it is like
it is like the place where how are you
today yeah yeah yeah it's just a
beautiful beautiful like officer
my son's mother moved them there because
she lived in in san francisco with him
at the time
and
won it and saw that newton was like
voted the safest place to live what do
you say about that you can't argue that
no and what was great was because i you
know i lived here with my wife in new
york so
that distance was a lot for me you know
by the time he was like six or seven he
was only three hours away so it was a
much more manageable situation oh yeah
for sure and and
but you must have been traveling when
did you stop like
really traveling i mean in terms of like
having kids and being there was that
difficult because
i imagine with touring and all that must
be i i dated a musician and she was just
constantly on the road yeah i mean
honestly i didn't stop really traveling
until two years ago like i wow just
before that i was i would go out solo
one summer
you know like i remember like i went out
with cunning crows like i would go out
you know solo and we would we would play
like and i would play first and then
they would play and then we'd come out
with matchbox the next summer and the
county closer moves we play and then i
go back out again the next summer solo
so i was always going back and forth but
the good thing is wow you know we would
take a couple weeks he would always come
on the road with me he's a musician he
actually just graduated from berkeley
college of music
no kidding you must get this a lot it's
deceptive because you you yourself still
look so young like i know certain people
don't age
uh you must take care of yourself but
you look young
it's really weird oh yeah no it's it's
really really odd i have no clean living
skills whatsoever because you did live
the life of a rock star like this
is was it like the stereotypical rock
star lifestyle
i mean i think okay i think parts of it
were like sometimes i feel like i was
more of a rock star when i was 16 right
yeah
cause i was like living on the road and
i was hitchhiking around the country and
so there was this kind of like like a
real vagabond
yeah i felt like i felt like sal from on
the road you know what i mean like
totally
so i just felt like i was living that
life and so wow how romantic it was it
was you know it's funny it was it seemed
sad at the time and it looked sad like
if i talk to my mother-in-law now
because my mother's passed away yeah if
i talk to my mother-in-law
she hates the stories about my childhood
because she just she just wants to grab
the little the younger people yes yes
yeah yeah well well because it was it
was so dysfunctional right i mean it was
so
not what
your wife has probably grew up with yeah
and you know but i feel like
if you did the math and we did it the
other way and i went to little league
and i had a really protective yeah
i don't i
somewhere you know in the suburbs of
florida probably that's true because it
was part of it just a means to get out
was it like a a means to escape
your living situation it was like my mom
you know my mom was really really young
she grew up in like the deep south in
this tobacco town right wow so she gets
married at 14 years old she has my
sister at 16 years old she has me at 21
years old and somewhere in this time
like computer programming was a brand
new thing right so she lied about her
age and would get this job at the ground
floor
and by the time i had gotten older she
had become like the head of quality
assurance for fiserv and citibank and
she had a really you know she got
herself up there but one of the
casualties of that was that that
childhood that she lost
she kind of went back to try and revisit
while before i was fully formed so i'm
like 15 16 years old and she like some
days she's gone for days i don't know
where to find her she's violent
sometimes she's drinking way too much
and uh
it just
it almost felt like i left because i i
wasn't missed
oh my god it was like her only way to
protect me was this unbelievably strict
kind of thing where i was like you never
leave the house you're always grounded
and so i would rebel against that and
you know throw giant parties in the
house that would wreck the party you
know they would wreck the house for for
weeks and you know and then justify it
because i was like well you're never
home and or she would be home and she
would leave like her bike or boyfriend
to stay with me for three days and he'd
be like let's go party like hell yeah
let's go a party oh my god these would
probably be like looking back it must be
wild to think that like i'm sure these
were guys in their like 20s or 30 like
probably younger people because she was
so young
yeah totally and she you know she was
one of those people i think who would
kind of become whatever she was dating
so like if she did if she was dating
like a businessman that we lived a nice
you know life and it was kind of
regimented and family but family kind of
like remember that movie
uh the
stepfather like the horror film yes yes
yes guy who played lock and lost was
like the he played the stepfather yes
what is his name yes
i feel bad cause he's such a great
character good actor yeah yeah um um but
yeah so
it was that kind of thing but then if
she was dating a biker we were at bike
week every year you know what i mean we
were like we and we were having like
biker parties at our house so my house
was kind of like all the other kids knew
that it was either
off limits
or anything goes right like at any given
time that's so interesting so was your
sister more of the grounding kind of
maternal was she more of a caretaker
during that time no you know my sister's
like i was really really close to
because you know we were children in war
together yeah yeah
she but she left uh at 17 so this is a
great story too so she leaves home the
last day of her high school the last day
of my sixth grade she's five years older
and she runs away and moves in with her
boyfriend in sarasota florida
and he's 21 she said so it's like a
recipe for disaster right and where are
you at this point where in florida are
you uh i mean we just moved to this to
orlando to like this kind of a penamenty
uh apartment building in orlando and so
my sister leaves but the funny thing is
is that out of that recipe for disaster
now my sister now has been married for
over 30 something years they're like the
closest couple this this guy that she
ran away with like it was the best it
happened to her yeah oh my god
i wind up finding music and you know
kind of fast forward into what you were
talking about like rockstar versus not
rockstar
the most rock star thing about it i
think was the fact that it was 25 years
ago and it was all happening privately
like whatever was going on nobody was
paying attention to it wow i mean this
has come up a bunch i mean i'm gonna
talk to i mean kevin bacon and actors
from who came up and rob lowe came up in
the 80s obviously like i mean he
he's he he got kind of busted doing it
but like yeah he was like one guy
like
up until there was youtube and internet
it was just like rob lowe he was the
only guy right right right but like for
the most part it was all being done and
i hear a lot of actors and i'm sure it's
even more true of musicians that say
well god if i had come of age uh as a
actor rox or whatever during this time
during such a transparent time you know
things would have been different and
uh i i can't imagine i'm sure
if that is the case and it and for for
you it happened right before
uh it all changed it happened right
before everybody had cameras
there was it said there's one of my best
friends in the world is a photographer
out in l.a he actually shot you once his
name is randall slavin oh i know yes of
course i know i it's funny i i run into
randall all the ts he knows every of
course he knows everything yeah yeah
he's kind of that guy he's like he's
this he's the one linchpin in the six
degrees of everybody game right like he
has been like he's one of my best
friends for 20 years oh nice he uh
so he put out a book called uh we all
want something beautiful and the whole
idea was that time in that that time of
the 90s he was like the only guy around
that had a camera on so he has all of
these these beautiful pictures from like
you know him and young leo and young uh
you know
charlize and like all of this this stuff
going on me and adam duretz you know 20
years ago drunk at adam's house you know
somewhere in the hot home something like
he's got something and he's got
continuing pictures that to his credit
he's never shared with anybody right uh
but he called it in his book so he wrote
in this book he he put out he called it
the last good time and that's kind of
like the way that we always look at it
like there was that last you know for
actors for musicians for anybody in the
public eye to be able to make a mistake
and that mistake be able to be something
that you learn from and not be learning
while you're taking public fire for that
mistake right right that is something
that will probably never
exist that is a time and
yeah i mean i see young really young
you know musicians and young actors and
i see them just kind of being young and
making mistakes that almost anybody
could make but then being held to some
sort of different standard because you
know because they're famous or because
they're almost famous i i was talking to
an actor friend of mine about this and
and i said you know we both determined
that like god if
if there had been cameras around during
our 20s like and having to explain i
look back at some of the interviews i
did when i was in my 20s and it's
embarrassing only because i didn't know
what i was doing i didn't know i didn't
have
any wisdom i didn't have an
understanding of myself and so to talk
about
the world and i did to be like a
mouthpiece for
um
or to be an authority on anything was
was impossible it was like i know i you
were throwing like you know in your
world like you were thrown pretty early
into some pretty big situations you know
i mean you were in you were in good
films with some really great actors and
you were you know so then you were there
trying to hold your own press junkets
you know with
much more seasoned actors at the time
yeah yeah but it's but to your point
it's like i was able to
make a lot of mistakes i was able to do
these things without having to answer
for all of them at each one of them i
mean i
um i i i i'm glad that the world is
becoming more aware of you know and
becoming more transparent i suppose but
um
uh it also it doesn't allow people to
grow in the same way
we were a band so when we first started
one of the things about us that like we
never really talked about we were just a
band that you know if you had our cd in
your dorm room you know then fan but we
weren't on magazine covers and we were
literally you know if they wrote about
us they would talk about the fact that
we were this faceless band that we are
this band full of 10 million records but
nobody knew what we look like why is
that why do you think that is
i just think because we we weren't there
was nothing sensational about us we
didn't speak for any uh disenfranchised
group right we didn't have uh you know
some political you know we didn't have
another persona outside of if you if our
music spoke to you
you know that was what we were so we
were just an embodiment of the music
that we made we were we were there for
your weddings and your funerals and your
parties and your saturday nights sunday
mornings but like nobody really cared
about what we did personally and at the
time i think we were upset about that
and didn't really realize how good that
was you know how much
our success didn't hinge on our
personalities which which was still
forming so you look back at that time
and
you're you're young you want
that you want certain trappings of fame
that you're not getting um
what what were they what steps did you
take to then
get get those things or try to try to
like reverse that you know would you
look at contemporaries of yours who who
had maybe flashier
public personas and and was that
inspiring at all
really i mean we look like a
transvestite baseball team softball team
like if you saw us
like i mean
like i've seen i go back on a cpu
there's anything wrong with that no no
no no of course not i mean
it's a fashion choice and we made it
there was a lot of leather pants and
there was a lot of like see-through
velvet shirts and it was the 90s and yes
were those your choices i mean or do you
have yes and no like you know we had a
manager you know who was way more
advanced than we were right this guy
michael
who had managed david bowie and he
managed george michael and he had this
this understanding of the visual aspect
of what we did that we didn't care for
you know we would have big fights at
photo shoots and be like he literally
once paid our drummer a thousand dollars
just to put on a sweater that he didn't
want to put on and so
and then but then you know there was
this sense of like we became an mtv band
when mtv really mattered
oh my god you guys were at i mean you
turn on the radio still all the way i
mean like you must hear it all the time
you walk into a bar it
that must that has been a regular part
of your life for for
you know probably more than half your
the time you've been alive i mean i
think it's it's part of why i feel like
big picture i don't want for anything
that i haven't got right because i think
i look and i realize that you know this
has stood the test of time for a long
time and it's attached itself to
people's lives in a very real way you
know and uh that was the goal all along
like it's the end of it's the end of a
cheesy book that goes and that was the
goal
and the boy realizes his dreams it
becomes a beacon of light flies
yeah so you're now flying off into the
yeah it's true it's like it must be
i guess it's not surreal anymore i guess
you become
accustomed to it like
yeah it's like it must be normalized or
is it still weird is it still weird to
hear like it's
when i hear someone say it's 3 a.m
i mean my brain goes immediately to it
that's how indelible some of your lyrics
are i go right i'm more surprised by the
amount of people that come up and sing
it to me
but also sing it in their their version
of what they think my voice sounded like
in the 90s so they're always like
there's
a girl
i bet no well because that was like the
sound that was like the there was that
her there was that sound but yeah you i
just listened to it um
it was much clearer than that what do
you what are you doing
thing if you listen to that first record
and and obviously if you listen to like
my last solo record and my christmas
record about like i mean it's i'm 50 now
so i mean that's 25 26 years difference
there so it's like uh i'm more
comfortable now you know what i mean
like as far as performing and singing
like i i kind of know what to do with it
as an instrument way more than i used to
oh i'm sure i i i was just talking to an
actor friend when i hear my voice
back then
jeepers creepers is a movie that's on
during halloween
of course i know that movie yeah well
it's hard to watch because because i
have this kind of like high nation
he's like i sound like a different
person to myself um but you must
i hear your music from back then and
maybe it's just because i've been
listening to it since
it you you put it out um but it feels
mature it feels it sounds good to me
what what about it how have do you feel
like you it has changed for you have
your sound how would you describe that
that
maturation
i mean i i think when you're making your
first record especially you don't really
know what you're doing right it's a
trial and error process and you're kind
of taking your cues from music that you
like you know like we were you know if
you're a big we're big counting crows
fans or a big uh
um
like live fans you know like yeah that
makes sense yeah
so whatever we were into like we have
some elements of that and we had a
producer to help us out and then you
start going your second and third record
and you get you get more sense about
like our third record
we really felt like
that was the record that must this is
what we sound like because there was
nothing else but us going oh we want to
make this song we want to make it sound
like this
and
a lot of it was at a time where you
could have a conversation about like
growing into your third record it's it's
hard to do that now if you're a band and
you find success right off the bat it's
it's a hard to mature into your third
record you know for a band
i mean it's it's sometimes easier i
think they're crafted and gifted crafted
you know pop singers and and uh that
have a team of people that write the
songs for them and they're very current
they have current producers and and
that's that's kind of machine it's a
collective yeah yeah and that's its own
skill you know without a doubt once
you're on top once you're making you
said you say you're selling 10 million
records and then like but there's not a
cl there's not like a real strong
identity to the band how do you deal
with the pressure of trying to stay on
top with that second third album
the second record you know what's funny
about i think first is just that
you have all of the success and there's
a sense of your living you have to live
up to it and then you have to live it
down right because there's no way that
you think you're as good as other people
think that you think you are i've heard
you talk about this in some form or
another but it's that feeling of when
you're in a bar just minding your own
business and somebody comes over to you
and he's like hey it's hey it's [ __ ]
justin long it's [ __ ] joke and the
guy next to us like i don't know who the
[ __ ] that and they're having this
conversation right in front of you you
go you don't talk to mom he's right here
he's like i don't give a [ __ ] about this
kid
i just want to have my drink you know
like there's a certain embarrassment
that comes with being mid-level famous
like if you're beyonce famous you don't
everybody knows who the [ __ ] you are
when you walk in the room you're
probably not you just bought the room
right right
when you're when you're just someone who
kind of has had success at the job that
you have and it's public
there's a lot of you know you suffer a
lot of indignities that kind of come
along with that kind of recognition you
know so we go through that in this first
record and we start off playing to
nobody in these small clubs and then
we're playing arenas all over the world
you know at the end of this three-year
period after that's
so
crazy
do you start how how does that album
start out i mean for people like trying
to understand the progression of that
kind of success you start out you were a
local band like bars you'd play bars
yeah we play like local bars and that's
why
outside of our you know we'd go to
different uh university towns around
florida playing games
and you know if you after a while if you
did well enough you got a thursday night
which was like the big night you know in
a college town and you could do uh you
could play half covers and half
originals but you had to put like four
one-hour sets
and uh oh my god you played all night
long and it was debauchery and it was so
much fun but fun you're a teenager
you're in your 20s like yeah yeah yeah
everything is good like no matter
everything is better than you ever
thought it would be yeah totally you
live in some [ __ ] town in florida
right and so you're like every place is
great you're like everywhere you go
you're legitimately glad to be there and
it's the greatest place you've ever been
i went to atlanta and i was like this is
the mecca of all you know things
um do you miss those are those days
sorry to uh sidetrack you but but like
just to put it in the next i want to
hear that but do you miss that time
how did you romanticize that time what
that was like um and and how do you try
to like
get some of that back yeah i mean it's
it's it would be hard to get back
because the it's everything about that
time has to be mixed in
with your lack of knowledge about the
world you know like like there's there's
two things that you need i think to do
what you and i do right you you need to
have
uh even if it's not
up to scale with some of the people that
we've met in our business you have to
have a little bit of narcissism and a
little bit of ego because you have to
feel like you're doing something that
people should see you know like that's
true okay and i think people need to
hear that that's true that it's just a
ballsy move that that's true i have a
feeling and you need to hear it you know
yes i'm gonna put i'm gonna tell you
about it in this microphone we're doing
it right now
and then you have to have a willful
ignorance to the ability like if you
really thought about the odds about
making it
you probably wouldn't have done it but
there was a sense so the very very
beginning this whole thing wraps around
to there was a sense of
at the end of it everybody was like well
you know that first record that's kind
of a fluke you know the one hit wonder
so
you know the sophomore record like i
remember even i was on a plane and i had
seen that we were just at the end of
that run and one of the guys from
hooting the blowfish was there and as we
walked off the plane i was like well you
know
it's good to see you and they're like
yeah good luck with that second record
man
you know uh
and then so we put out our second record
and then the song bent comes out and
it's our first number one hit ever right
off the bat and it becomes like the
biggest song that we've ever done is the
first song on our second record so then
things get interrupted and then it
starts to seem like we didn't realize at
the time we thought that we were
successful but we didn't realize was
that first record was the ticket to get
on the ride we weren't even at the party
yet but that was like the the thing that
said okay now
come come over here because this is
where the big boys are playing
[Music]
we talk a lot about health on the show
i'm trying to stay healthy i want to i
know life is short but i want to extend
it for as long as i can and of course
health is more about diet and exercise
though those two things are very
important it's also about gut health and
i've been taking probiotics
they've helped immensely they've helped
some of my less savory
habits i don't fart as much okay
but if you have type 2 diabetes you are
going to need a little bit more specific
probiotic that's why pendulum
therapeutics is so important it's the
first and only biotech company to
one isolate an important beneficial
bacterial strain and two put that strain
into a convenient new probiotic rich
capsule that is formulated to help
manage type 2 diabetes and nurture your
body's microbiome pendulum glucose
control is the first and only medical
probiotic clinically shown to help
manage type 2 diabetes when taken with
medication over time people with type 2
diabetes lose the gut bacteria that help
them digest fiber and manage blood
glucose levels for those with type 2
diabetes diet and exercise alone are
often not enough to manage it so the
best approach emphasizes diet and
exercise and
like we said a healthy gut microbiome if
you or someone you love has type 2
diabetes take control of glucose levels
with pendulum glucose control use code
long at pendulum life dot com to get 20
off your first month of membership
that's p-e-n-d-u-l-u-m-l-i-f-e
dot com promo code long for 20 off your
first month of membership this episode
is sponsored by ritual we all have
rituals i have one in the morning that
has lately involved protein powder the
fact is we all need protein it's not
just about muscles protein helps support
bone health and it satiates yes yes it's
very satisfying that's how i use it
sometimes if i just want a little if i'm
getting a little rumbly in my tumbly as
we go through life protein needs change
so it's important to choose a mix for
different life stages rituals essential
protein is a delicious plant-based
protein powder with three distinct
formulas designed to meet the body's
changing protein needs there's the daily
shake 18 plus which is a complete amino
acid profile featuring choline
an essential nutrient and common dietary
gap there's daily shake 50 plus that
adds calcium hmb to the mix helping to
build and maintain muscle mass for
healthy active aging and there's the
daily shake pregnancy and postpartum
it's formulated with extra nutrient
support to meet the demands of pregnancy
and lactation yes i bet that can be very
demanding lactation are you ready to
shake up your protein ritual our
listeners get 10 off during your first
three months at ritual.com
short ritual even offers a money-back
guarantee if you're not 100 in love
visit ritual.com
short s-h-o-r-t today for 10 off your
first three months
[Music]
so after that first record are you
thinking
especially consider your hump your
humble beginnings are you thinking this
is it i'm like i'm getting this thing
i'm getting to do things that i never
thought i'd do i mean was that the drive
did you feel like you had achieved
whatever your vision of success was
yeah i think so i mean i also think
there's a there's a sense of like well
that looks nice you know like you said
when i said well that kind of seems like
that would be good
yeah and then you're on the road then
you're opening for certain people and
then you think well i know i want to be
yeah and yeah and you also like
a lot of writers i know you're kind of
fueled with the self-doubt you know it's
it's kind of like the distance between
the person that you want to be
and who you are that that art exists not
the idea of like i am the [ __ ] you know
like that's not at least that's not the
kind of songs i was writing i wasn't
writing i am the man music you know i
was right you know like why you know why
don't i love myself
yes
yeah but i think that's why people i
mean looking back i'm sure it's easy to
see now that that's why people connect
with it it's it's um there's a truth in
it that it's like very universal i think
that and the leather pants i mean
and the sweater
yeah equal measure
but what like what do you also like
let's face it i mean i there are certain
bands from that time and that is like
the time that i was growing up that was
the time where i was like discovering
the world and girls and you know the
world and there there's um
there's a the hookiness there's a
they're [ __ ] catching uh those songs
and do you when you write something like
that that goes on to become
a hit do you how quickly do you know
were there any of those songs that
became hits that you knew right away
were there some that were like surprises
is it just a mixed bag can you ever
really know
and the answer is yes in the sense that
i i think we kind of felt like we were
doing something special and especially
when we were when the record was
finishing up and we were playing it for
people who knew you know people in the
business this is kind of you know this
just sounds really special using that
word and i was like okay um
i think
even with an idea of success
you don't really know what that means
i didn't like i didn't really think
about
the fact that there was a direct
correlation between having a lot of
success and you're going to have to
start working your ass off you know like
i didn't think that success meant a lot
more five o'clock in the morning calls
and flying right
multiple you know like
just a long 17 hour days you know i mean
i just thought it was going to highlight
reel that i saw for everybody else you
know yeah well what was the appeal as
you were going up the ladder like what
what was um what was making you happy
doing that like what was it
being out on the road was it the freedom
of like you mentioned sal i mean like
was it that was it the romantic idea
that you had of like just being out on
the road and meeting people i think i
think carrying that gypsy lifestyle like
continuing that there was something
really cool about that doing it in this
capacity um you know that whatever that
giant mom-sized hole that i had in me
from all the stuff that i had gone
through i would get that filled up every
night with people you know like they
would just
it would make me feel better about
myself you know and all i would have to
do is do the thing that i love the most
in the world and so when i step out and
do that the reward was huge because it
was you know people coming up and
letting you know oh my god i think
you're the best girls i'm not talking to
you you know that was that was amazing
well you had mentioned at the at the bar
now i'm imagining like oh god guys at
bars can be really tough and i can
imagine what they must say to you but
like you you had alluded to like some of
those moments like what
how how do you respond to somebody who
does that some jackass who's like i
don't know who he is i have to say now
it's smooth it's not like now it's it's
the
that's the kind of like hey
hey man it's a hot one
i mean i think people expect less of me
now
he's watching like a television station
for this light rock fm thing with like
like she's speaking you know and it's
smooth as a song and he's just he just
calls me up he's like i don't know what
the hell went wrong i just don't know
what went wrong but but
to meaning like it's everywhere i mean
that was everywhere well no meaning that
like you know when when he wrote smooth
it was like it was a sexy song of the
summer and hot young girls were dancing
and then it became the divorced dad like
we became the steely dan oh that's
really great that's generation that's
funny and then time went on and then it
just you know kind of moved itself just
back into popular culture but i mean
that took a ride that song how do you
come to like collaborate with somebody
like carlos santana because i remember
thinking like that's an unusual pairing
it was and i i just wrote the song i
wasn't supposed to sing on it and then
uh
no kidding like my voice on the demo huh
and what's funny now is flash forward 20
some odd years later and let's forget
about it you can't forget about this
yeah we speak almost every day like
really oh no okay like we maintain this
friendship like i on the next record i
wrote songs for him and like for him and
mary j blige and him and seal
and how did you come up with matchbox
20. i've always wondered that i'm sure
you're sick of answering this question
right curious
um i've not never been asked that
um
well uh
time to move on then unfortunately
no no no it's you know it is it's
obviously it's it's a ridiculous name um
i've talked to other like darius rucker
i talked about booty and the blow like
his that story of hooty and the blowfish
is like i love those stories i i love
the idea of naming things like you know
one of the i keep saying when i think
about having a kid which i hope to do
like i i'm always curious how people
that came up with names for kids and a
band that lasts and and darius was
basically like i kind of
kind of had regrets about it he was like
it's like it's kind of silly and like i
don't even matter
it's funny too because i i had the the
dubious honor of
naming my son
and then 20 some odd years later
helping him name his band so i got to do
oh funny that's wild yeah how cool
so we were uh we had a we had a deal
before we had a name because we were in
this thing called tabitha secret like
playing locally and that band broke up
and i got signed on just on these songs
that i was writing
and we needed to kind of form a band me
and the two other guys that were left in
matchbox 20. and so from tablet the
secret or secret sorry
and so we were like just brainstorming
every every kind of shitty you know like
we just had notebooks of stuff
and this guy came into a bar and he had
on a like a soccer jersey that had a big
20 on it
and there was a bunch of patches and
like right at the top was one that said
matchbox and so it just like read out
matchbox and 20.
and uh i i like i remember like looking
over it it was like this rollins college
hangout like oh yeah by orlando
yeah and so i remember like looking over
at the these kind of drunk frat boys
next to me in the booth and i was like
let me ask you like would you go see a
band called matchbox 20 and he goes
matchbox twitty
and i was like oh that sounds cool when
you yell it like that
so
at the time the curt loader test like
okay so yeah
kurt loader was mtv news he was like he
was the he was like a serious one he was
like
he always looked like i don't know these
[ __ ] kids are doing but i'm going to
give it to you
like i can always imagine him going you
know in other news matchbox 20 hours i
was like yeah i could see him saying
that i could totally oh that's so funny
yeah that's really funny yes yeah the
curt loaders
that's like explaining to somebody now
like so i got my abacus out and that was
well
i know i know i know it's funny matchbox
20 i've just lived with for so long as
as a person in the world um digesting
what you've put out i
it seems like a perfectly like i don't
think of it as like a
a good or a bad name because it's just
been so
synonymous with
music and it's been so
it's rob and it's justin right i mean it
is it is it's yeah yeah i i am i'm so
sorry i know you have to go but we have
a lightning round rob
oh i'm in okay all right um
i listened to it to a lot of your
podcast so you're doing a really really
good job oh man i you alluded to that
that is so kind of you that is this is
an effective group of people that you
interview and i think you do a really
good job individually with all of them
and i feel a pretty good company too
because
there's not a whole lot of musicians and
like you know being with people like amy
mann and people
that's good company of musicians i
yes i agree i i for me it's a thrill to
get to talk to
people such as yourself and amy because
i've been listening to you for you know
since i even ever could have conceived
of doing anything like this and and was
ever out really in the public world so
um and amy is the man i mean she really
is
she's the best she is
have you worked with her i have not i've
just i i've admired her like yeah that
whole period growing up like her and sam
phillips you know like just these yeah
just bad ass singer songwriters uh and
she would don't know she's just always
fascinated me with that patty griffin i
would love to have online yes yeah there
are people are you is is that an
influence because i've just started
really like getting into country music
like uh waylon jennings and those guys
yeah i mean i grew up in south carolina
so
when i was really young there was i
didn't know that there was anything else
besides willie and whalen and conway
twitty and barbara
and dolly parton i think that was like
you know this this songwriting for me
was that story between
growing up in like country just all
storytelling songs right yes
drinking men writing these beautiful
stories
and then i totally got into like the the
second english invasion you know like
echoing the bunny man oh yes
so there's like this pop
storytelling thing oh okay that's
at the time just just um aesthetically
um that kind of makes sense there was
there was a fusion of that there was
some i remember getting into like brit
brit uh new like the new wave and um
james and pulp and those bands um how
did you let me ask you i don't mean i
don't want to keep you longer but but i
just no i i thought you had to go
oh no i'm fine i have a session but i
they know that i'm coming on late um
okay thank you rob uh i'm just because i
was late
i um
oh so did you when you were a kid yeah
like
what were you that like did you cringely
ever
decide some days like you would it would
wednesday you would go to bed and
thursday you'd come to school and you
were like a different person because you
like had a new persona you wanted to try
on
um i this is that's funny it's jogging
some memories i do remember doing a
persona in church having a look in
church i remember because because that's
when a lot of people were i felt like
maybe gonna look at me and so i remember
i'll tell you one that's really
embarrassing
i
remember
being aware i thought i remember being
really like thinking michael j fox and
jason bateman and and like kevin bacon
guys that were really cool right and and
i remember thinking that the common
denominator the thing they had was that
they didn't have like a big upper lip
and i felt like i had really big lips
and so i remember just i remember being
in church and i going like this
sitting like this and looking around and
thinking this look cool i'm doing a face
now where i'm hiding my lip um
and i remember thinking it looked cool i
must have looked ridiculous i remember
my mom saying to me once
like what are you doing
with your lips
and you're kind of teasing me about it
like this like doing uh that i remember
i remember doing like a british accent
um after i had seen
i saw this or an australian accent after
i saw this movie gallipoli that i think
mel gibson was in um
uh yeah there were there were moments
like that
i guess nothing
nothing like a whole new persona but but
you would have died
i was actually just thinking like you
you did take it farther than i thought
like i was thinking like you know outfit
choices and you're like you're like
tight your lip and talking with
accidents and like
you're in the witness protection program
like you don't have anyone to recognize
justin long yeah like i would do an old
time i would other people probably
thought i was insane um no but i i i
never changed my
i i remember feeling like i didn't have
the right clothes that was that was
always a thing like you know i didn't
have because i grew i grew up in a town
that was like
there were a lot of rich kids in the
town it was
and we didn't have you know that kind of
money and so i remember thinking like
that's what it means to be cool to look
a certain way i did you know it's funny
i we grew up with no money and
and and like when we lived in the south
in this little town we didn't realize it
because nobody had money right
we went to florida
and we were still in a shitty little
apartment but around us were people that
had money and like i remember the first
time about school when this hot girl was
talking to me and she's like uh like
where do you live
oh we live in a shady brook apartments
and she's like oh you must be rich and i
didn't get it
until like 10 minutes later i'm walking
down the hallway and i was like oh [ __ ]
i i you know what i mean she was being
sarcastic yeah i was like oh i'm poor oh
funny isn't that wild and and
and that that it should mean something
to somebody that there should be value
in that
yeah like and what value like come up to
a stranger just to point out the fact
that they have so much you know i know
but so many kids behave that way it's
funny i i
i know how many adults don't do justice
i know i know i know isn't that crazy i
know i i love those stories and now i'm
thinking about dolly parton a lot where
that a lot of that great music comes
from and whalen and how many of those
people grew up so so poor and so many
darius
not to keep now he's on my mind who
talked about that how he had
nothing but they all of those songs
those stories they would tell came out
of just being in the house with his
listening to music and how that's what
they had to do to like entertain
themselves there's there's something
it's funny i mean it's like you had
mentioned earlier which i think is so
interesting like if you had had a normal
you know
by the books uh upbringing you know if
your parents had been together if things
had gone like
smoothly right uh what would have
happened i mean what would you do you're
a smart person like i mean even if i had
you know like you i'm sure you had to go
through this at some point too like
there was a certain point where i had to
i had to consciously
say no to things that might
become a career
oh yeah yeah i mean because i had made
this decision
but then you know as you get older you
know
older you know in this case being like
18 19 20 21 and
all of these viable options to kind of
get in on something are going going by
and you're like no but this is you know
i this is what i got to do so i'm doing
like every other job i'm doing
construction and painting and every
restaurant job and like anything that i
could quit on a friday and get a new job
on a monday if i had a gig and they
wouldn't let me off kind of a job you
know like i used to make futons and i
used to deliver beds um i was a roofer
in florida for six months oh no [ __ ]
that's a tough job i've heard oh god uh
what is next by the way what are you
working on now
oh so uh we're actually in the middle of
a new matchbox 20 record oh no it's been
a while
yeah we weren't we weren't going to like
our last one i think was in 2014 and we
were going on tour
and we weren't gonna we were just gonna
put out a song really we didn't feel
like making a whole record and i was
working on a solo record yeah and uh
because of we my wife also she has
immune disease and so okay
working with it for like the last 15
years or so she still can't get
vaccinated we she's we still can't
really go outside oh
yeah we couldn't do the tour this year
and so we moved the tour so in light of
a tour we're like you know what [ __ ]
let's we were already working on some
songs let's just make a record so now
we're kind of deep in making an album oh
that's exciting um yeah yeah so you're
in the process of that that's exciting
uh
um well isn't that funny when you're
like
something good did come out of like i
mean like you know you make the most of
a situation like that i made a christmas
album that i just that i put out just
that's right that was something that's
what i've always wanted to do you know
yeah what is that what there must be a
degree of pressure doing a christmas
album knowing that i mean ken what it's
you're singing iconic songs well i did
half originals and have you yeah covers
i did were like except for one of them
they were kind of like they were like
like a dolly parton christmas song in
this room
they were kind of a little less known
which might be okay
that i wrote that people don't know and
then other songs that people don't know
right
that's right right it's like well summer
covers but yeah like covers sort of
implies that they're like well known
yeah but that was not the case oh that's
funny that's fine i was really glad to
be able to do it because i that makes
now i've done it the same amount of solo
records as matchbox 20. oh [ __ ] wow no
kidding and
what is it is the difference just
at a certain point do you miss the is it
as simple as like i missed the game i
missed the i missed doing it with justin
and i mean there's
i like i go solo because there's certain
things that i can do that i can't do
with the band there's certain decisions
that i make that would get changed in
the process of making records and right
with the band there's just there's
something like i'm not writing all these
songs paul's writing a couple songs
kyle's writing a couple songs and then
you know we write some of these together
so it's just it's just you can't do that
alone whatever we're going to wind up
coming up with is something i couldn't
do alone and but you still get along
with everybody obviously and i love and
we love playing live like i don't we
don't love our best record together it's
it's gets very you know rare but yeah
but uh but we love touring
together
yeah that's a very rock sound to make
that's a very rock and roll rare yeah
yeah you're like kitty cats
the claws come out
um
but well well yeah i can imagine playing
live what a thrill that must be and and
like take the feel i it's funny there's
no way to really ask this question but
it's it's the one i'm always most
curious about from
somebody such as yourself somebody who's
like
a rock star who's like had the
experience of
seeing a sea of people and feeling a sea
of people
knowing what you're playing i mean like
knowing your work and and
just kind of singing it back to you and
i mean that just must be
i i i that must be a feeling like none
other you know it's it feels like a
community every night like there's a
little community it's like a little
village you know that you've set up in
and you're the town crier
yeah and people come out and you know
they're just it's it's all part of their
night you know like especially like
those outdoor venues there's people on
the lawn they've got their blankets and
you're a part of their night it's more
than just
it's a community out there yes that's
cool yeah it must be amazing and so so
the tour that you would tour that album
yeah so yeah so we'll tour we moved the
tour to 2023 this summer so we just kind
of like just replaced all the dates so
fingers crossed
life could be a dream sweetheart
hey parents this one's for you wundery's
kids and family podcast little stories
everywhere transports your family to an
imaginative world with enchanting
stories and exciting adventures in each
episode hosts virginia madsen and robbie
damond read an original children's tale
if you've been looking for screen free
entertainment for your kids little
stories everywhere encourages your
little ones to use their imaginations in
one of their latest tales you'll hear
about mark the unicorn he's just like
any other unicorn except he doesn't have
a horn that makes him an easy target for
school bullies
that is
until he runs into the most popular
unicorn in school sprinkles and their
unexpected adventure changes his life
forever listen to little stories
everywhere on amazon music apple
podcasts or listen early in ad free by
joining wandery plus kids in apple
podcasts or wondering plus in the
wondery app
in business competition is the key to
success every product you own from the
shoes on your feet to the phone in your
hands got there because of cutthroat
business decisions wundery's podcast
business wars brings you stories about
the most well-known in the world and how
the decisions they make shape what you
buy and how you live with over 50
seasons to choose from you'll hear about
the fight for your feet with nike versus
adidas the battle to control the
smartphone market with iphone versus
blackberry or their new season that's
covering the delectable world of ice
cream haagen-dazs versus ben and jerry's
tells the story of these two legendary
american brands that have traded licks
trying to conquer the global ice cream
market each season of business wars is
entertaining fun eye-opening and will
help you understand a little bit more
about the world around you listen to
business wars on amazon music apple
podcasts or wherever you get your
podcasts listen one week early and add
free by joining wondering plus in apple
podcasts or the wondry app
hello hello
[Music]
what is your favorite emoji rob
your go-to um
the the the
the winky one you know like with the
tongue out there
like
yes yes well because you know it's good
it helps contextualize [ __ ] with your
emoji right right right right so if
there's any doubt about like oh is he
being serious winky face um
who is your first celebrity crush
alyssa milano okay yes
i mean comes outside
yeah that is a it is not an uncommon
answer and um i i had the occasion to
ask her the same question on the show
and she said um
uh-oh
rob thomas yes uh but but a man named
robert thomas who was from her uh
i think was ralph macchio yeah
um well you know
shoe that did a number for me oh yes
the sister-in-law
when i was oh oh yes of course uh what
was her name she was so cute yeah
frizzy hair really all i can remember i
only know really no willie oh really
that the uh rob that was the first
i'm so glad i could do this now for you
um that was the first impression i
remember doing was max wright who played
the dad who was like um
i remember being like in second grade or
something like oh
oh alf no alf kate and i were
all pretty good all right
it is spot-on
the kids did that muscle memory you
never forget that oh
he was always
exasperated
oh kate and i
want to just have a night alone
it's amazing that's spot on
where's the cat why are you looking at
me
um well
it wasn't what a crazy [ __ ] by the way
i went back during the pandemic and and
revisited that show it's it's so good
really al i i i swear to god the writing
is it's like there are poignant moments
there's like
lessons that like really important kind
of like political like social commentary
on a very special sort of elf well it's
about like it's about when you see
through the lens of like
immigration now too and like
it's about
you know it's it's the ultimate
immigrant tale um
not to be pretentious about alf which is
probably the first time that's happened
that's a
podcast um i did my college or something
it's um
what is your favorite uh let's bring it
back to
the basics what's your favorite ice
cream flavor
oh i like i like um the i like
soft-serve chocolate vanilla swirl oh
great yes um
did they have carvel in in florida
no but i've been here for like 27 years
and yeah you try fudgy packaging okay
give me the fudgy the whale cake oh my
god yeah by the way voice is that guy
for the most disgusting voice
what a crazy voice to be on the
the the commercial for tootsie roll pop
has not changed since it's like 1962 the
licking the black and white owl yeah
well like
i has had this idea that like it's a two
zero pop they like every year they go
and they have a marketing meeting
they're like so listen uh commercials
we're gonna stick with the all right
we're just gonna stay with the owl and
everybody's like yeah we're gonna stay
with you
bro
hey move on
it's true that's how i feel about the
guy of course i'm gonna do that
yes yes
what is your favorite holiday
christmas
yeah okay
oh yeah oh yeah so that that that album
must have been a you know long time
coming
yeah when we're big like we you know we
it's all christmas movies all christmas
music oh what's your what is your
favorite uh special of the christmas
specials oh probably
uh there's the muppet the muppets of the
muppets yeah christmas carol
they also did one called a very muppet
christmas that had like um michael
jackson was in it and uh no michael
caine was in he was in a very much okay
uh no he was in the muppet christmas
carol
scrooge
and it was and he's he's it's
unbelievable and he says in an interview
that's one of his favorite movies he's
ever done and he's so good in it he's so
good in that you're right amazing he's
he is against those muppets
yes heartfelt uh yeah i um
it's funny we were i was just talking to
i think it was simon pegg on the show
and i said we were talking about the
muppets how much we love them we used to
have a question about the muppets but i
i said um
if you remember emmett otter's jug band
christmas of course of course okay okay
so your response
was the polar opposite of his so imagine
never having heard of emmett otter's jug
bang christmas and then having somebody
mention it
it's a crazy sounding name and he was
like it was the only time he got a
little bit like incredulity like what he
was
no i've never heard of that it was um if
you've never heard of the muppets and
you're trying to explain it to somebody
that's not yeah no no no i know you know
with the frog he's married to the pig
there's the guy with the bear the
comedian bear you know
and there's that the guy with that the
hook knows who loves chickens who like
maybe sexually kind of yeah i'm not sure
if you're [ __ ] the chickens or not
but
yeah yeah yeah the italian immigrant who
throws sardines goes to sardines
oh i love the swedish i had forgotten
this error of this swedish chef somebody
reminded me where he had actual human
hands at one point i mean i know
they used yeah
that was
speaking of movies in an acclaimed movie
that you were embarrassed to admit you
haven't seen
like people shame you for maybe
schindler's list
okay okay
yes i can see why i own it
yeah i'm still waiting to get around to
it don't don't spoil it i won't spoil it
uh i i you know it's funny yeah it's
it's i i understand that i understand
the impulse to
why first i understand the shame but i
also understand
why you haven't seen it because
i i feel that way about 12 years a slave
i i know it's going to be incredible i
know it's a great i saw 12 years a slave
i'm not trying to like completely shield
myself from the past atrocities
but it just it was just for some reason
like there was that it was you know
that's like i never saw the english
patient but it just it's not as much
i think it's
i realize this is more required viewing
than english patient yeah but both that
claimed i think the english placement
patient won the oscar and i was so into
movies at the time and
it was just i mean a part of it is like
it's three hours it's long
right it's an epic and you know excuse
me i think i've seen clerks like five
times so there's really no excuse
well i mean
but we live it see the way i've been
consuming things lately rob like i find
myself going to the funny things the
easy thing the stuff that i know from
the past because i i there's so much bad
[ __ ] in the world i kind of don't want
to i and i know like schindler's list i
should re-watch schindler's list and i
i saving private ryan somebody that was
their movie um that they they haven't
seen and
yeah
um
but it is a great movie you should see
it i can't believe you haven't you
should be back
what is a game show pastor president
that you would love to be a contestant
on
what is it like is it the 60 is it the
60 thousand dollar period or whatever
yes
things that it's kind of like taboo
right it's like yes i think michael
strange i never remember the dollar
amount is it 60 000 i think it is yeah
let's say
no okay okay no that's true
well yeah but nobody's listening to this
do you drink i was like i remember like
me and vince stiller once hanging
outside of a bar going you know listen
we're gonna you know uh i'm he's like
i'm moving to chap aqua so we should get
together we should i said yeah but we're
not going to so let's just wave our
hands around like this
that's funny like we're going to make it
happen yeah
that's funny
do you drink coffee or tea and if so how
do you take coffee
yeah what how do you take it uh i i like
a splint like a just a little thing of
splenda
and um but i like the powdered coffee
mate really
yeah i don't know why it's just that's
my that's my jam you must have grown up
with that no i don't like you know like
if i'm out you know i just have a little
cream and two percent our little two
percent milk and you know sugar like
it's not like i can't not drink coffee
any other way yeah but when i'm home
that's my jam because i drink a lot of
coffee at home yeah it always reminds me
of a moment of the big lebowski where
he's mixing himself uh i think he uses
the powdered kind
uh yeah powdered yeah um
yeah that's some pretty redneck [ __ ]
right there
if you could learn another language what
would it be
uh you know uh
my wife would be a lot happier if i
learned spanish and i never did what is
your favorite cereal rob
honey nut cheerios is what i buy
okay
but lucky charms is what i don't buy
because it's my favorite yes
like i just i have a habit of walking by
and like seven times a day just pouring
dry cereal into my hand and eating
something yeah
yeah
but but but like i get it because the
honey nut cheerios satisfies that like
there is like a slight there's enough of
a sweetness right but the other thing is
like like i would just go crazy on it uh
if you had to choose a different first
name besides rob what would it be
me and randall i think we named
ourselves ace and razor so i think
yeah
you know that it comes equipped with
finger guns
that's right
that's funny who's ace and who's razor
not that it matters i'm ace okay that
makes sense
um uh if you had if you had a sandwich
named after you what would be on it the
rob thomas uh yeah i'll take a rob
thomas like a six-inch rob thomas
i think um i would just steal another
famous sandwich and put my name on it
because that's just how i roll like i
would just be like they're like oh isn't
this just like an italian sub and i'd be
like no this is the rob you know because
this ad but you have to make it slightly
different to make it the robbed like uh
like what would you add um let's let's
say like uh
good bronx bread some salami
some melted uh imported swiss oh wow
that sounds yeah
maybe oh definitely some tomato and you
know maybe tomatoes stay on it hot like
when you make a grilled cheese yes yes
it gets a little mushy yeah that could
be really good nice um uh if you
what is your favorite tom hanks movie
joe versus the volcano that's crazy we
were ch i just talked to adam powy about
that uh how it's such an underrate he
hasn't i haven't seen it in so long he
has not
yes as does he how funny um
you know what's funny is i once
met up with with tom hanks at this event
we were talking i told him that and he
told me that it's one of his favorite
movies as well oh wow that
was that frank oster it's meg ryan right
it's um egg ryan's yeah she plays three
different parts oh wow
and he uh it's it's this i mean it's
silliest movie of all time but there's
something to me that's just unbelievably
sweet
and just
kind of amazing and he's so likable like
i don't know i just i'm so in love with
that oh that's so i'm watching joe
versus i gotta watch that now um because
you never really see it it's rarely a
thing that's like you know those classic
comedies are on all the time um
that's it's like if it's on i it's like
you know that in the big lebowski you
know like yes yes
um would you rather take a time machine
to the past or the future right oh i
guess the future
yeah okay that's the only like i've seen
you know the past and before i was born
i've done a lot of you know read a lot
about history it seems like a whole lot
of [ __ ] was going on back there
that's true
pretty scary
you know and i'm only going to get to
see a finite amount of time ahead of me
so i'd like to kind of shoot ahead past
that's a good point okay that's a very
good point
uh are you a night or a morning person
night yeah uh
beach or mountains do you prefer
beach and do you have a preference to
toilet roll over or under
over
yeah uh your wife i think under uh is
like the sign of a psychopath
okay and please finish this sentence rob
thomas uh life is short so
be good to each other well said uh yes i
i
i can't thank you enough for doing this
for for taking the time but also like um
i was excited to talk to you but but now
i'm like i'm even
more grateful that i did because this is
just fun and and i've always i've loved
your music for so long i'm really glad
we're glad to be a part of your history
now that's very nice yeah oh man it's
been a pleasure having you on i'm glad
you wanted to do it and uh i let's let's
let's make a plan let's wave our hands
around and make it yeah let's do it
you're in boston
i'm in new york i'm close um
it would be great to run into you in the
world yeah i look forward to it
yeah thank you so much man for your time
[Laughter]
well that just happened
so that just happened oh that's
such a bad impression well let's forget
about it but it's not that i know that
it's funny he laughed about how people
do that i know i don't think he sounds
like that maybe he doesn't no in fact we
just talked about it he sounds more like
adam duretz than counting crows who i
don't think sounds like that either yeah
it's a little bit more neutral than that
that was a that was i don't know i
didn't know they tore together that it
that makes sense it does make sense that
was just such a like you said such a
popular sound that like her i guess from
pearl jam yeah and creed i mean a lot of
those are
a lot of those bands connor stern
see creed sounds more like that to me
but i don't think rob thomas did i don't
know he i don't think he did or else
would have you send that back to him
um oh yeah yeah
like kind of like a few minutes after he
had said
people do that they like come up to him
oh really you annoy him by singing
and you uh uh
you did the same thing
it must be so weird to have that no or
else forget about it well because it's
you know it really is in my some of
those phrases are in my my head as those
songs that's how you ubiquitous that's
how popular they were what a crazy
upbringing he had
how
turbulent it was and like what he went
through
it always amazes me when people
have upbringings like that and then they
end up
so
normal so well adjusted and like and
interesting and like
well just he seems like a normal guy
like yes he seems like a guy you'd be
friends with he'd be fun to hang out
with you i was thinking that yeah it was
easy that would be a cool friend for you
to have i think yeah i i felt like we
could really it didn't it didn't seem it
seemed like
by the end it was like oh yeah like
let's hang out sometime
i i think that because you got along
well and it's like yeah you have enough
actor friends let's face it at this
point i know it'd be cool to have a
musician friendly it would be cool
you confessed to him that you used to
hide your
big lips in church and do you remember
saying this yes and i was wondering
two things one
do you still feel at all insecure about
the size of your lips and two
who are you trying to look good for
after you remember yeah i do i think
there was um there was always a girl
nearby that i
you know wanted to look good for but it
was probably some girl it was probably a
family um i'm trying to remember was it
just like your cool face that we made
fun of you for yes like your handsome
face well it's a little it was more
extreme like like your speedman phase
yeah like max miguel like our friends
back then we'd call it laserface
remember that oh yeah they would call
like cool looking guys laser faces like
um scott eastwood scotty's laser phase
yes scott eastwood like even james dean
like there were guys back then that had
laser face who were like sure looked um
josh hartnett yeah his laser face
it looks like they're in pain they're so
handsome that they're they're struggling
it's like painful it's like they're
so handsome and beautiful that they're
like a bright light yeah that shining
it's shining back into their face yeah
that they're like so you tried to do
that basically
so yeah basically i probably had an
eyebrow thing going but i i remember
definitely hiding my lips like this like
this i look like this well it's a great
look
you should do that more i must look
really cool uh but no i'm not i'm to
answer the first part i'm not um
self-conscious about my life i i guess
now i like having big lips
not big lips but all right i wish i
hadn't said that
i like how you
tried to name some of the other matchbox
20 guys and you're like oh you're like
yeah you're like it must be so good to
get back together with those guys you
know like trying hin and sam
no
no i you said justin justin but you were
like justin
no he had referenced
as a joke me doing it with something
with me
i i mistakenly thought he was talking
about a member of the band oh so i
remembered that i was like but after i
said it i i saw that he didn't register
any he seemed kind of confused for me no
that makes sense so i don't think there
is a justin in the band no because then
he like he listens to 30 seconds later
he listed them and i think kindness i
think to like i think he knew that i
didn't i think so too which is a really
nice move
i liked him a lot
well i hope i hope you're friends with
him yeah me too and not just podcast
friends i know i have a lot of podcasts
chances are you're just going to be
podcast friends
but you never know what's wrong with
that but you guys have a good idea you
guys having a good time out yeah me too
um let's read a letter okay from bree b
breeb
breebie subject letter with oh yeah
would you rather hello there boys
hello there boys
my name is sabrina boker and i'm from st
louis but i'm a lewis or louis you say
louis i say louis
you do yep st louis but i'm a freshman
attending northern arizona university
lucky yeah i know i have to say that i
never liked podcasts until i saw y'alls
pop up on my spotify account oh i'm glad
hearts did pop up due to my unnecessary
deep interest in actors and justin's
comedy work i couldn't resist yes all
right
after spending my entire work shift
listening to the conversations you have
the countless actors i've always loved
and looked up to you guys helped me
realize that you were all just as normal
as the rest of the world trying to get
by i'm glad we made you realize that and
it's so nice that you like my comedy
work i kind of breezed over that maybe
she likes
the same thing that lil nas x likes yes
perhaps maybe she's a chipmunk
chump chipmunket chipmunk ch chip chip
sh
it honestly makes me want to become some
sort of famous
just so i could sit and chat with you
guys about life you guys brighten well
why would you have to be famous to do
that tell us on the show i see yeah um
you guys which socks i mean it would be
nice to talk to everybody yeah you know
uh but i feel like we are kind of
talking to her like we're engaging with
her we are yeah you don't feel so
defensive okay um you guys brighten
every workday for me and i love the
chaotic energy of justin start middle
and nancy
thanks
thank you
chaotic energy you're like a tasmanian
devil yes
a little tigger i had some tigger energy
this week not to mention the criticism
between you two reminding me of my
sister and i
thank you for all of your comedy and
inspiration oh thanks bri you are
greatly appreciated by a gen zer so here
are some would you rather questions i
like being appreciated by chancey me too
yes i prefer i mean i i love old people
and i i respect all respect
but to be appreciated by somebody
younger absolutely you know why you know
what i don't know i i think it's because
they have more time in the world
oh really oh interesting they have their
finger on the pulse of what's happening
now that's part of it but for me it's
uh because i think
that's the group that
doesn't that like i don't feel connected
to oh the most yeah that's true so it's
nice to know that that you reach
somebody like that you know that i've
reached someone but that like they
connect with they don't think i'm some
old boomer yeah yeah well most probably
do exactly so when one doesn't it's like
oh yeah i know i know breath of fresh
air i know what is that maybe just to be
connected more maybe that's why people
like babies and like young people i mean
that's why kids are nice to be around
care so much about what babies think of
me because they think they don't have
much of an opinion not their opinion but
like 20 year olds
yes but i i just mean like the energy of
being around a young like youthful
energy yeah of course um
yes i know i don't care about
an infant's opinion
isn't that funny that like an infant i'm
not related to i don't care at all what
they think of me no i know i mean in the
moment you want moments to smile and be
positive but but other than that yeah
because you know they're not going to
remember you and right isn't that crazy
i know we digress um would you okay here
we go yes brie has would you rather
would you rather have to impersonate
every single person you meet as as a
first impression
i often do that anyway um or never be
able to impersonate anyone ever again
wow that is a great question okay
let's see here um and this i'm assuming
it's to their face right i think so
would you rather have to impersonate
every single person you meet as a first
impression yeah i think so but then does
the other does the second option mean
that you can't
you can ever impersonate anyone but even
like behind their back oh yeah i think
so that's how i'm reading okay
um because that would make it difficult
that would that would be real one more
question sorry just to get a handle on
this do you think it means like when
when she says meeting someone yes do you
think that includes like
a really quick you're at a party and
your friend is introducing you to five
people
and you have to like
do an impression of
or is it just like a a real meeting like
a conversation i think me me like this
is my friend greg oh hey you have to be
like hey greg oh man i would definitely
that gives me anxiety thinking about it
i would definitely never do an
impression of anyone
yeah i learned to live with it yeah i
guess but but if meeting is just like a
meeting meeting where you're like
getting to know someone and you have to
slip in it uh an impression i mean how
do you i think i might keep the
impression that might be would you
rather have to impersonate every single
every single person you meet
as a first impression i think it's every
single person i would definitely not i
mean do you get introverted
for you because you have more of an
instinct to do impressions it's easy
it's much easier for me to answer this
it's very difficult for me to answer
it's a really in fact i would
maybe say that you might not be able to
resist i don't think you might have to
keep the impressions i think i'd have to
and just
it would be awkward occasionally
obviously um
i would be it'd be disrespectful
especially if you were meeting like the
pope oh my god or someone who has like
oh
like
like you know and i'm an actor yeah
that'd be tough that would be tough
that's why you can't pick that because
then i don't who do i meet what
dignitaries do i mean no and people who
have like
disabilities and stuff oh
yeah you would
yeah you would like hurt a lot of people
oh so you would have to give up think
about that yeah and think about
disabilities or you know yeah okay
that's a great question bree
i think i would have to you're right
because of the potentially sorry to
yeah but that is a huge problem it will
happen in life yeah i know i'll meet
somebody with yeah um so here's another
one would you rather never be able to
apologize again wow these are good but
show an endless face of remorse
endless endless
like when you're sorry for something
yeah okay not for the remainder of your
life yes okay or apologize for
everything but never look like you mean
it oh that's a good question that is
interesting wow
this is my remorse face
it's like cutesy why is it like huge no
well you make a remorse face
that's cutesy too
i guess remorse is cute
yeah how about this
that's bash that's cute you're like well
i'm cute
um
remorseface is hard without how was the
remorse face i don't know it's hard to
not look kind of cartoonishly cute okay
so but how would you apologize without
look like and but never look like you
mean it so like sorry about the see but
then it would sound like an insincere
apology yeah it's hard to like not
make your face look the way you i'm
really sorry i'm really sorry about that
i'm really really sorry about that
picture like like it was smiling i'm
really sorry about that picture of ryan
phillippi apologizing for something
yeah it's true i'm very sorry about that
i apologize for my pillowy lips
you know i would um really i don't think
it can be done i think
but if it can be done i think words are
it's easier to commute uh communicate
with words than than your face
so i think it's just more i think it's
more efficient yeah so i would be able
to yeah
there'd be a way to do it if you
looked like you didn't mean it
to look like you never mean it is like
i'm so sorry like you'd be smiling i
guess yeah it'd be smart it'd be smart
i'm so
i'm so sorry
but then you'd have to say like no i
know that i look like this right now but
i i swear to god i'm sorry these are
both really tough it's tough um anyway
thank and then he says thank you again
sabrina boker
uh thank you so much short for sabrina i
guess so sabrina well i thought it was
uh
brianna
sabrina sabrina that makes sense
or brianna i'm sure people do
um
sabrina sabrina's a great name but i
would go with bree too if i were a
sabrina it's a good letter yeah no great
letter and she's man she's a freshman
and not just because she's jessie and
she likes
spread the word but that doesn't that
doesn't hurt it's not hurts
spread the word over there in the
northern let's give northern arizona
university a shout out yeah i wonder
what their mascot is all right while you
look it up i'm gonna tell people how to
write into the show okay life is short
at wondery.com and you don't have to be
gen z and you don't have to go to the
university of northern arizona
um it's in flagstaff cool which i've
been through and their mascot is louis
the lumberjack well that's cool
a lumberjack i wonder why
mascot it is a good mascot what was your
mascot at colgate raiders the raiders it
was the red raiders when i was um a
sophomore and they changed the name
because it was deemed defensive oh
so now it's just raiders oh wow you know
they changed the name of the cleveland
indians and the washington redskins
commanders i know yeah commanders
washington commandant i think so i i i
and they changed the cleveland indians
too the guardians the guardians i think
it's the cleveland guardians the
guardians yeah
guardians of i mean that mascot was
super fast oh it really was the
cleveland indiana i can't believe they i
know that for so long and redskins
obviously like the difference between
the washington redskins mascot and the
cleveland and indians is pretty major i
think the mascots
yes
you know one is more authentic looking
authentic and kind of like heroic right
whereas the crowd the cleveland indians
is like
yeah looks mocking exactly yeah yeah wow
so the cleveland guardians i'm pretty
sure i know they changed the name i'm
pretty sure it's the guardians who do
you think the chats are going to pick
they get two picks they got number four
and number two there's an amazing they
need a receiver they need a password you
need a pass rusher yeah there's an
amazing pass rusher out of
oregon is that him he's yeah
yes yes oh man
anyway oh okay well back to the show so
thanks thanks rob thomas yes
yes thank you hopefully justin's future
friend and yours hopefully my future
acquaintance yeah well um i don't think
i have the chops to be his friends
he doesn't seem like he cares about like
what fame he listens to the show
sometimes he does so maybe he likes me i
bet he does or maybe he fast forwards
through the beginning well rob if you're
listening
write in and let us know what's your
favorite part is yes life is short at
wondering.com by the way feel free to
write in you don't have to be gen z or
in matchbox 20 right but you but you
could be in matchbox 20 and write in
yeah um thank you rob that was such a
great talk i hope you're still listening
and thanks to brie for that great letter
and to all of you for listening uh all
the lumberjacks over in northern arizona
and we'll talk to you next week oh and
the brewers at baster and the raiders up
at colgate that's right and the
fairfield prep jesuits yes our our alma
mater our high school a lot of shout
outs yeah i like ending shows with
shadows uh so thank you
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it is co-hosted and produced by
you christian long it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie fee allen and
see you producers michelle
senior producer audio audio engineer is
sergio enriquez
[Music]
and the big man the big executive
producer yes marshall louis
the big company called wandering yes
[Music]
so you're supposed to call them what
church of latter-day saints sure but
what do you call a person in the church
the letter they say he's a letter this
he or she is a letter to say
seems like a lot of that seems like a
mouthful well there's lds lds and lds
sir
i don't know if you can that's
identifiable yeah i'll just have there's
a mormon ever got an lds or ever been
upset with you for saying mormon no
because they know me
where did you hear this that they don't
like because i got like i got a good
friend of mine there's a lot of things
oh and he said i don't like to be called
he's uh one of the big time elders so
utah yeah he's one of the eldest ones
yeah how old do you have to be to be an
elder well you could be any age it's
just being
how long you've been connected with the
church oh okay so you could be like a 15
year old elder no you couldn't do that
you'd have to have some college and go
to the graduating from the college but
you don't have to be like an old person
to be an elder no
if you like our show please give us a
five star rating and a review and be
sure to tell your friends the next
episode will be out in a week but you
can listen to it right now ad free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app you can follow this show on amazon
music apple podcast and the wondery app
or wherever you're listening right now
in the episode notes you'll find some
links and offers from our sponsors
please support them another way you can
show support for the show is by filling
out a survey at wundery.com survey so
thank you for supporting
you